hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from CUDA hua around 5:00
the rapid tournament it's Magnus Carlsen
with the white pieces against maxime
beaugeois growth it's a very interesting
game as you all see I'm not in my usual
settings I'm in mock irska as I
mentioned I will be visiting a chess
tournament here and I have my laptop
here so I hope everything is working
properly the sound the interface hope I
didn't mess everything up as I didn't
use my laptop last time I used it for
recording was during the World Chess
Championship in London so hopefully
everything is working fine if not you
know do do comment on it so I will try
to improve it for the next video if I
will be recording more videos from here
that being said let's check out this
very nice game and I've seen you've been
suggesting some other games too but I
will try to cover them not sure if I
will be able to but I will definitely
try to make time so without further ado
Carson has the white pieces and he opens
with efore and I do have to mention if
you hear some loud noises like screaming
yelling or some music you know don't be
alarmed or anything there are a lot of
drunk students well around here so
hopefully that doesn't happen but if it
does you know just so you were prepared
for and of course that means Carson is
ready to face Maxine's c-5 ended the
night off as Maxime holograph is known
to be one of the greatest night of
players of this of the day night to have
three we have d6 by MV LD 4c captures on
d4 Knight captures and Mountain Knight
to f6 with Knight to c3 and a6 the
knight of Defense is on the board with
Bishop to e3 by Carlsen and now comes
nice to g4 as the bishop is now open to
attack we have Knight to g4 Carlsen of
course is an interest in trading bishop
for night so we have Bishop to g5 it's a
very no mine h6 Bishop to h4 g5 Bishop
to g3 and Bishop to g7 I played this
position with the black pieces once in a
classical tournament but I I didn't
really know how to play it III don't
remember who I played against but I lost
that game but you know if you like it of
course well you are more than welcome to
play it as you can see Maxine
is it and he's known to be one of the
the greatest experts with Queen to d2 by
Carlson and now comes Knight to c6 and
Carson doesn't wanna allow the straight
or further defend the night so just
Knight to b3 retreating and here there
is a known game from 2015 Rosen opponent
Mario played against mucky-mucks
enforcer holograph in that game maxim
went b5 Maxime was able to win the game
but here he goes Bishop to e6 he
deviates from that line from 2015 and
Carlsen replies with h4 and this is not
a new position still this is all theory
of this opening G captures on h4 Bishop
captures on h4 and now there is a known
game from 2011 from the amber rapid
tournament cross and plated against Gary
shock and grief Luke played Queen to b6
here Carlson was able to win that game
but here
Maxine goes for b5 and now again it's
not a new move f3 is a known move in
this position but Causton goes for F 4
and F 4 is a new move in this position
so it would seem that this time calls
and output are prepared maxi marshal a
graph and now we have a completely new
game so let's see what happens first b4
I'm grabbing more space on the queenside
dislodging crossings nice - a less
favorable Square with Knight to a4 and
now Queen to c7 s Carson will be
castling queenside it's always useful to
have a queen on the C file and on the
other hand you're moving your queen out
of this diagonal so we have castles by
Carson a queenside castle that rook to
b8 now and kink the b1 just always a
useful move black still has a dark
square bishop you never know when a move
like h5 Bishop to h6 may happen you know
so always it was full move King 2b one
especially when facing the Sicilian and
now Knight to a5 just trying to trade
pieces and improve the position of Wax
Queen Knight captures with Queen
captures and now comes b3 defending this
night and here a Carlson also sets a
trap and it's a very nice trap for
example Bishop to d7 seems like a very
normal move
you wanna either dislodge this Knight
from here let's say Knight back to b2 or
you will capture it and then mess up a
white pawn structure on the Queen side
but
it would be a huge blunder as a wife can
easily win the game here by just going
Bishop captures on e7 and now of course
if you captured an Queen captures on d6
is sufficient so black would probably go
Bishop captures here but now just Queen
captures and b6 attacking the rook here
black can go Queen b6 defends the rook
offers the Queen trade but now just be
captures here and after captures
captures you would have this position
where if the a pawn is lost then the
position is lost like would have to
defend and then a lot of ideas are
winning for white you can just go I said
Bishop c4 to maybe d5 to c6 and that
will be game over for black but you know
a very very interesting position where
if something like this seems like a
normal move but it would lose you the
game so you do have to do something
about this pressure Carlson has in the
center Queen back to c7 not allowing any
captures here and now just the Bishop to
e2 continuing development with h5 by
black and now cross and goes f5 pushes
the bishop back with Bishop to d7 now
attacking the knight here and of course
Qasim does not react first he captures
the knight here will bushel character
son g4 and now you have to capture on g4
as well if you try and do something like
Bishop captures here then f6 would be
will be deadly ich actors on f6 just
Bishop to g3 now if you capture them
white can always trade the rook here
let's say captures captures captures and
our Bishop captures and e6 will be
sufficient for a win rogue d8 a pin for
pin captures captures and after captures
he would get this position where Crossin
is on the exchange in an in a winning
position so after Bishop captures on g4
by Carlsen with H captures on g4 by
Maxine and now cousin finds a very nice
way how to win a pawn and that is Queen
to g5 just attacking the e7 square here
that means this is the threat of
checkmate and also the Queen will
capture the g4 pawn so here you might
think okay why not Bishop captures on a4
surely now the Queen defends d7 square
everything is alright but the bishop on
g7 is also under attack so you do have
to take care of everything
so Maxine takes care of it
one move Bishop to f6 preventing
checkmate getting the bishop out of
harm's way and our cousin just grabs the
g4 pawn we have Queen captures in g4
Bishop captures an a4 with Bishop
captures and f6 rook captures on h1
first not allowing of course recapture
Sun h8 with check rook captures on h1
and now he captures on f6 and here
Carson has to decide whether he goes B
captures on a4 or does he first want to
trade rooks the problem is with rook to
h8 if you go this then you get King to
e7 rook captures and now black doesn't
capture the rook but he has this very
nice addition so Bishop captures on b3
you have to capture the bishop otherwise
you're getting checkmated so only after
C captures you would get Queen captures
on b8 and here it's a pretty much a
drama queen and pawn and game where the
material on the board is equal across
and of course is not interested in this
he goes B captures on a4 and now King to
e7 not allowing any rook to h8 tricks so
cousin allowed his pawn structure on the
Queen side to be ruined with his beak
actress and a 4 but it's not all that
easy for black to take advantage of this
first Queen to f3 by Carlsen he's
preparing Queen to d3 as of course the
black will try to create a lot of
pressure along the C file we group the
c8 now Carson has to defend the C do
pawn queen to d3 and now a5 just
improving the position we have rook to
d1 now course and also make sure that
MVL has to keep an eye on the d6 pawn
and now
Maxine goes for rook to g8 his plan is
rook to g3 and then he wants to go rook
to a3 from there the Queen can maybe go
to c4 maybe pressure the a to pawn a lot
of ideas are possible here
Crossan plays Queen to e2 doesn't want
the g2 point to be captured so now rook
to g3 becomes possible
roof to g3 we have Queen to f2 attacking
the rook but also keeping an eye on the
a7 square which will be an important
square in this game rook to a3 has
played as planned by Maxine and now
cross and just goes for g4 interestingly
if Queen to c4 going for this idea now
Queen to a7 will be a way for Colin to
defend and enjoy his extra pawn King f8
and I'll just go into a check came back
to 7 Queen
seven check and let's say after King f8
now Queen to d5 just blocking and the
the capture on e2 is impossible here you
would get captures rook captures and
after rook captures an a4 route captors
and b6 cousin would once again have this
rook and pawn in game he would be up
upon and it would be well it would be
hard for black to play this on the other
hand if you try something like Queen to
c5 this is the best idea for for black
here just after captures captures now
you don't go for the a four point you
just let's say if white goes rook to d5
now you defend it
rook the c3 and you try and hold this
position and it is definitely tenable
so after g4 Maxime doesn't go for Queen
to c5 or Queen to c4 rather he
immediately goes for the pawn grab rook
captures on a4 but rook captures on e4
doesn't work it's a blunder
unfortunately for Maxime so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
winning idea for Magnus here I'll give
you a couple of seconds not too much
because you know the drunk students
might start yelling so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you are an excellent pusher of pawns and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
g5 is the move and now you see the
problem yeah white will win the f6
square no matter what black does if
black doesn't capture there's also this
problem of let's say if black moves
Queenie - that's the idea
Queen B 5 will come with check and the
rook is vulnerable there so let's say R
ok 3 just defending but now pawn
captures here and now you control the
very important east 7 square let's say
Queen c5 not just Queen to a6 and you
will have a lot of checkmating ideas
here black will not be able to hold this
you can go rook to h1 you can go or the
other way around it will not be possible
for black to defend all the threats so
here at maxime decided to simply capture
it but now of course the move you had to
see f6 this is the idea across and head
again the e7 square is 1 we have King to
e8 and now cross and continues in a
similar fashion with Queen to e2 going
for b5 and now maxime wants to get the
rook into the game as quick as possible
first b3 and it's also a tricky line
because now if Carson Carson just goes
for this Queen to b5
it's a it will be a force to draw this
is what Maxine had in mind after Queen
d7 you cannot capture the rook so now of
course I would have to settle for a draw
after Queen b8 check and now just Queen
D a twin b5 Queen d7 Queen B a check and
here crossing would have to repeat moves
if he doesn't if he trades Queens then
it's not a problem for black just a
capture son b3 rook captures on e4 and
now you have this position where the
material is completely equal but black
Soria and not completely cool black is
up upon and the df6 point is now a weak
bond because cousin just sacrificed upon
for the game some sort of an initiative
so after b3 Carlsen of course does not
get fooled by this he goes a capture son
b3 says thank you for for your pawn and
now rope the b4 hoping to bust open the
position with a 4 but now across and
wastes no time just 'if I've a temporary
pawn sacrifice but the rook will
recapture the pawn with the rook to d5
and rook captures an e5 we have D
captures an e5 there's really no better
move and now comes Luke to d5 going for
the pawn king to f8 getting the King out
of the way and now just Queen to h5
cross and is now threatening checkmate
as you can see the pawn controls or both
of both the e7 and the g7 square we have
looked aged for preventing checkmate but
now Queen captures on g5 Queen g7 is a
threat now maxime defends it we have
rook to H 7 and now Carlsen plays Queen
to d2 and it was in this position
I don't know 42 that maxime beaugeois
Grove resigned to the game and an
excellent victory for Magnus Carlsen in
round 5 of this very nice rapid
tournament he also won a game in round
four against Sarah Kerrigan
I will try to show it if I if I manage
at a time but you know we'll see how it
goes
what if you resign well now there's
really nothing to do here you have to
prevent rook to d8 that's the immediate
threat so let's say kinky eight but now
we just go rook captures on a5
of course the threat is rook to e8 and
after black prevents this Queen to c6
now you get rook to e7
now what do you want to do let's say
well Queen to c8 preventing any any
tricky ideas now comes Queen to d5
already threatening a lot of nice
you can capture on e5 and after Queen to
b8 defending the pawn now you get to
this Queen to c6 check King to f8 and
now a beautiful mating tree of course
you will see it Queen to d6 check a nice
temporary Queen sacrifice but it's for
it for a checkmate Rock day a Czech
Queen has the block here here doesn't
really matter
and of course rook will deliver
checkmate the pawn still guards these
two squares well not that one but
obviously these two and of course it's
only one line but it's one of the nicer
ones I decided to show so after this
Queen to d2 move Maxime
decided it was it was enough for him and
he resigned the game so Carsten still
undefeated in this tournament I believe
he's undefeated for I don't know almost
70 games now if you if you consider all
everything like the classic rapid and
and the blitz which is which is
definitely a lot it's not close to ding
clearance a hundred game win streak but
you know he's getting he's getting there
we'll see how it goes so that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it we managed to
finish this video without any any
yelling or music which is much more than
I've hoped for and yeah that's pretty
much it
I will definitely try to do another
video so hopefully you know we will see
more games from from day two of the of
the coup de huaah rapid tournament so I
think you'll I will see you soon and as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here sorry I'm a bit too
disoriented as you know I'm gonna anime
in the different settings so it's not
going smoothly as usual but you know
sorry about that but thank you I will
Susan and have an excellent rest of your
weekend